here all right so here here's another
here's another good question I have my
own answers but I I definitely want to
hear yours why is it so typical that
women will say one thing and their
actions are totally different
I don't know why I know what's up we all
want to know I feel like we're so
unaware almost because the world just
lies to us all the time because because
when I was trying to so like there's not
very many men that tell you the truth
and are like real with you so I feel
like sometimes we don't even realize how
full of [__] we are okay
I don't know that's my answer off the
top of my head but I have to think about
it more because you mentioned what do
you think women what was the question
again why do we say we want one for
instance for instance as an example
typical example yeah women will talk
about it how they want I want this
gentle guy nurturing guy I want this guy
who this is everything
I'm gonna give you a little bit
different of an answer I just think that
our media today panders to women in such
a way where they construct kind of what
you should want or what you should be
like and I think a lot of it is to
take money up out of their pocket right
so I think like there's a construction
of Disney which then feeds into wanting
marriage which then feeds into the
multi-billion dollar marriage industry
there's a there's there's different
constructions that would make women more
materialistic it's different I mean even
like a wedding ring you know you ask the
the average woman on the street what
type of ring do they want and it's just
like wait a minute but that's just a
rock that's in the ground what really is
the value outside of the perception of
so there's a lot of things yeah so I
think like so it's like this wedding is
like twelve thousand dollars
wedding was 35 Grand yeah and that's
cheap yeah for all the Jewish Community
that's very low we had 200 people have
100K 200k weddings we cut our list down
from 400 to 200 years I just don't it
makes no sense it's stupid it's so
stupid it's like you're paying all that
and the average marriage lasts eight
years it makes no sense I'm hoping I
just want a little a little bit Roi yeah
it makes no sense man we're going to
talk about marriage too but my my
feeling is this I think a lot of the
time women really don't know what they
want and they constantly change their
minds it's not necessarily their fault
it's your emotional brains
but I'm not going to say you don't know
what you want I'm sure a lot of women
have an idea but I think that would
change I think they can change a lot
fine you don't think they do all right
cool
what I what I've come to realize is I
think like now with the dating market
and a lot of the red pill podcasters and
content creators are talking about this
and I and I completely agree with it the
the larger the market gets in terms of
how the world is is so accessible where
women have access to so many different
men
most men just have no chance in the
dating Market it's it's so so true and
there's a small percentage of men that
have access to all the women and I'm
regurgitating this but I it's such a
valid point so most of the women are
complaining about the same group of men
and those same that same group of men
has so many options that they're not
always going to treat that woman the way
she might want to be treated in terms of
taking her seriously and whatnot
so I think as a guy
most women if I I'm curious to hear your
thought process and your thought process
is I think that you need a balance of
mostly toughness and masculinity with a
little bit of sensitivity because
sensitivity isn't sexy if there's no
masculinity
but on the flip side if you're overly
emotional and overly sensitive and you
have a little bit of masculinity that
isn't very attractive so I think a
little bit of sensitivity is good so it
doesn't scare a woman and she feels safe
but you you need both sides and I think
that's really what it comes to what do
you think what's your take yeah I agree
yeah
comfort and a rule and I think that's
why it's really confusing for like women
is what we want because what arousal
around us doesn't necessarily Comfort us
that's true so it's like
kind of think of a good example like
you know a guy being emotionally
available they'll say Comfort Comforts
us for the short term but like it
doesn't hurt us like we don't want to
start with you after 100 they want a guy
who's gonna open the door for them and
then smack there they walk through the
door
no you just you need you need that you
see that you have that accountant who
who marries that girl who had a crazy
college life and she settles down with
him because she knows that this is the
safe bet but in the back of her mind
she's thinking of her biker boyfriend
when they were 17 they used to be on
every room of everywhere and this
accountant is just not doing it and she
can't get that other guy out of her head
again and I and I get it though I
understand why that process is there so
that's why body count matters so much I
often get this question on the channel
you know I don't know if you want to go
into this question go ahead bro go ahead
yeah but I think that's why that's a
major component to why I you know talk
about the importance of you know body
count or what they do with their past so
like when I talk about the first thing
earlier I'm just thinking about
um how you've allowed these dudes in
into you with little to no benefit to
yourself besides the short-term
gratification of tacos
I should have made that clear from the
beginning yeah
but you know there's just such a
short-term benefit you know within that
so it's like it's something that I think
about and you know we all got different
parts and anatomies outside of you know
what like the feminists might say today
like we're all equal but our body parts
are differently so like a question that
we ask in the car is to say like you
know would you prefer a son that has a
thousand or a daughter that has a
hundred I think we should ask that
question and see what you guys think
about that absolutely the sun with a
thousand
absolutely I'm in as a guy who
definitely was a promoter in New York
for four years and had a very good time
oh you went off you know there's a
little bit of this a little bit but you
know it it really is uh it's not it's
not it's not really a fair question for
because you know there's double standard
always in that you know women
always get criticized for being or
shaming when you know it's multiple guys
that they've been with but for men you
know you get applauded for how many
people you slept with if I can inject
real quick and I'm sure you've heard
this and I know you've both heard this
it is a fair double standard and I I'll
give my reasoning as to why and I know
you guys have heard this
it is extremely easy for women to get
even if they're average looking you can
go out at any moment in any at any venue
and all you have to do is find a guy now
that might not be the ideal guy it might
not be the hottest dude but if you your
goal is to get as a woman
it'll happen nine times out of ten the
same thing if you're a dude it's not for
most guys homie maybe with most guys is
most guys don't have the balls to
literally go and talk to women 100
that's the difference if you go and talk
to women and show confidence you know
you can
pretty much with many women I can say
without a doubt that I'm that I am not I
I don't have that issue it's like fairly
fairly simple but not nearly on the same
level even if you're a good looking guy
you're gonna get rejected a lot but you
can
I mean have you seen those two a lot
more it was like a guy and a girl at one
out asking for
I saw that and there's not even a
comparison they were they were both very
good looking and it was like just up to
strangers do you want to have sex right
now and it was half the guy said yeah of
course guys are like dogs
because for women also I think it's a
safety thing right if a guy just comes
over and says you want to [__] you're
going to be a little concerned you don't
know who he is he's way too upfront yeah
if it was a safety thing you see oh my
gosh did you guys see that Tinder
experiment where they had a super good
looking guy and it put that he was a sex
offender the girls didn't care
a child oh my God right they don't care
I'm just saying if the girls were that
okay I'm sorry if women were that afraid
of safety we weren't that afraid of
safety I wouldn't hear why can't I walk
home alone and I you're walking home
alone at night and now you're afraid of
the world that doesn't make sense to me
it makes no sense
no there's listen we if we're calling it
a hundred there's some freaky [__] that
women are into and they just don't they
will not be outward about it some will
be you're like does this channel I I
forget what it's called it's a
the guy's name is like Ryan Pollard or
something
all he has is on the show and the things
they I can't believe the women are are
willing to say the things they tell did
you hear about this one where um
one of these girls was dating a guy she
went to a gas station met up with her
ex-boyfriend he died of her she went
back to her boyfriend and he went on her
right afterwards I didn't see that first
off how do you do that second of all how
do you have the
or the lack of dignity to go on in the
internet and say it's nuts to me and
it's being promoted everywhere and
everyone's like yeah you go awesome
great fantastic the West I think I mean
if we keep going this around America's I
mean some people are into that you know
well maybe yeah
my boyfriend's like I don't know like I
actually think he wasn't yeah I think I
think he has to be he has to be he has
to be I think he was but I don't think
most guys prefer that no I don't think
so either but definitely I mean
first off I've been I would be cheated
on so she'd be out the door anyway but
especially after that oh my God man I
don't know I don't even know so okay so
you know what's so crazy about that like
why is that not so I'm like why is that
not we need to make a lot we're putting
that right there that's a fair question
read that book it's like by Tucker Max
or whatever it's like I hope they serve
beer in hell
it was like when he had the realization
that it was like he was hooking up with
a girl right after or and she was going
to somewhere after like her boyfriend or
something and he he was this guy like
Lady Killer and he he screwed girls all
the time and it was like the realization
when he sat down and said that's
probably happened to me at some point
now you're planting some ideas in my
head I don't want to think about it
because many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible